most of those caravan immigrants are now
in the United States for processing and
are expected to file for asylum but the
grips American organizers are vowing to
get every single one of mostly those
Central Americans into the country and
to stay permanently meanwhile the DOJ
has sent dozens of prosecutors and
judges to the border to make sure those
asylum claims are valid they have their
work cut out for them let's discuss the
situation as it relates also to Mexico
as this Caravan is now kind of an annual
thing Geronimo Guterres the Mexican
ambassador to the United States is with
us mucho gusto
Giroux stolen hador all right I'm not
doing the whole thing in Spanish
although it's tempting let's talk about
what's happened here I mean I think
people initially were wondering how do
people do this annually they take this
long trek through Mexico at one point
the Honduran ambassador to Mexico
actually marched with the migrants
saying he was on orders to do that which
was wild but how do they manage to get
across the border in New Mexico and then
for weeks make their way up to the US
borders Mexico doing a nice event really
started several years back to calling
attention on human rights
fundamentally in Mexico and the United
States and Mexico are obligated by
international law on Asylum matters and
the truth is that in this year the
caravan got so much attention mediatic
lee that they were people were much more
interested and some of the people
actually that were not original in the
caravan joined I joined it that's a
that's the truth the kerbin started with
around 1300 people most coming from
Honduras most coming from Central
America yeah and the truth is that I can
understand why here people get the
perception that the Mexican government
is not doing much which is certainly not
the case first of all I'll give you the
figures that over the last ten years
Mexico has repatriated around 1.1
million people according to law and due
process international and you and you
process how many the caravan folks did
you deport well from the from the
Caribbean many
of them were repatriated around 200
supporters every Patriot they were
appropriated according to legal process
and you know how many around 260 so
there are thousands every several other
actually were offered some form of
humanitarian assistance or
regularization in Mexico and some of
them indeed got to the border then most
of the people do not want to stay in
Mexico I mean I kept saying if you want
to get out of trouble in Honduras why
not be part of Mexico or applied at
Asylum Mexico there's something called
the safe the Mexico has to be called a
safe country correct that's correct it
is in the interests of both the United
States and Mexico I think to make sure
that wherever migration take place
through our countries and between our
countries is legal safe and orderly and
that's where we're working in fact we
have very good cooperation with CBP and
DHS we don't see eyeball to eyeball on
everything we are in favor of securing
the borders and having secured but no
wall or you don't care about it well as
long as you're not paying I think we'd
love that chapter because I'm never
leaving a bond not the Mexico part
please know that sometimes Mexico is
first-rate Mexico is a favored having
secure borders we don't always share the
same view as the administration you're
on how to achieve that goal yeah this is
I got a plane Vicente Fox cuz he was on
my show not so long ago former President
of Mexico very interesting guy very
colorful figure let's watch okay so we
shouldn't have a border god he's in
creating borders do you have a fancy
like you're okay with Canada happen this
will happen in this next generation okay
because we are going to be on a
one-to-one no border is that a common
feeling in Mexico they tell you get rid
of them now to tell you the truth I
actually served with Brigham Fox and to
disagree with him on this one border
success for a good reasons and good
borders make good neighbors and that's
the truth I that's not certainly what
everybody believes in Mexico we believe
in having secure borders and and again
we're working very closely with the
United States in that regard
why what about your southern border look
I know the United States is actually
offering assistance
in the southern border it's not a lot of
less this stuff's not public but is
trying to help you secure your border
it's how long it's about 800 miles long
or so is that right oh my we work in our
you know our southern border we're
working very closely with different
agencies from Mexico and security
matters people are streaming across
though right you got a thousand those
Caravan members came across but again if
you look at the numbers Laura you will
see that we have work again according to
international law and due process and
repatriated over 1.1 million people last
ten years that are essentially coming
through our southern border right but
why is Jeff Sessions if you guys are
doing your job why is Jeff Sessions
saying this let's watch we are adding
thirty five Assistant United States
Attorney's to the border the prosecutor
illegal entries into our country we're
also announcing that we're moving
sixteen or eighteen actually
immigration judges to the border we are
not going to let this country be
overwhelmed people are not going to
Caravan or otherwise Stampede our border
people are just outraged about this I
mean I I got to meet you month or so ago
two months ago and you know you lived in
Texas I mean you're I mean if you were
American you'd be a conservative
Republican let me just say that about
the ambassador here okay so you're in
this too you're too tough pickle though
because we've now had a two hundred and
thirty eight percent increase month to
month
excuse me year to year from April of
2017 to April of 2018 two hundred thirty
eight percent increase of illegal border
crossings that's southwest border not
coming from Canada but but the miles but
the numbers Laura if you look at the
year before they were weighed down they
were could that's cuz Trump had the
tough rhetoric we're gonna build the
wall and Mexico's gonna pay for it and
it was like yeah I'm not gonna try to
come stand back and go I'm not gonna go
make that track again Trump is not gonna
let me in but Trump's letting people not
Trump's letting people in we're doing
catch and release I'm blaming us for
this not you we're catching them
processing them and saying bye have fun
with your sponsors and they never come
back but the truth is nightmare both
Mexico in the US I think have a shared
interest in making sure that whatever
immigration takes place is legal safe
and orderly and we do need to make sure
that there are sufficient avenues for
that I think that
if you look at you know the history of
emigration to Mexico you will see that a
lot of the Mexicans that have come to
the United States did so because they
did not have an opportunity or very good
opportunities in Mexico and that's not
the fault or the responsibility of the
US that's or not but the US should also
recognize that there's a need for those
people here and you know Mexicans don't
have a chip implanted in them saying go
and break the law that aggression is
actually down it's way down this way but
the northern triangle is up that's where
a concerted effort between Mexico and
the United States to stop these people
from making the trek because if it's if
it's 200 or getting in under Asylum
which is phony sorry we're gonna have
two thousand then two million I mean
it's gonna keep getting worse and worse
I'm challenging mr. ambassador but last
year last year that's why we had the US
and Mexico Co convene a meeting which
took place in my I remember address both
the development side of the equation and
also the migration and security side we
should do more of that we cannot be
satisfied with what is going on
neither Mexico nor the United States nor
the Central Americans but we need to
work I mean in Mexico we had a lot of
remittances going back to Mexico for
years and years those are down now but
they're they're still hefty it's a good
amount of money Mexico likes those
dollars coming back in you don't want
the guns from the United States going to
Mexico we don't want the drugs from
Mexico coming to the United States or
the cartels or the human traffickers we
don't want any of that but I'm telling
you Honduras
they love the American dollars going in
it's 19 percent of their GDP well you're
smart you went to Harvard I only went to
a small school in New Hampshire yeah I
mean 20 percent let me do the math
that's one-fifth of the GDP right that's
a lot that's a lot so well it's good to
have you on and we went back and I think
I think there's a lot Mexico in the
United States can do to improve its
relationship and I'm optimistic about
NAFTA I'm gonna say that right now are
you optimistic I'm moderately ok we
still need to tackle some issues yeah
NAFTA is very important for the US and
also for Mexico I think there's a
serious and a good faith effort on both
sides or the trees actually to get it
done and I think next week will be
crucial if we have a left-wing new
president of Mexico
ain't gonna be any the NAFTA is not
going to be a good deal the Reno
ago she ation won't be a good deal got
to get it done now mr. ambassador thank
you thank you very elite to see you